i am nick gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Bob Bowden at
Freedom Fest author of the great school
choice movie the cartel Bob you got a
new venture underway tell us what it is
well underway meaning we've started
working in producing pieces but it
hasn't launched yet yeah it's called
choice media it'll be a choice media TV
run following in the footstep to some
other great movie websites and the idea
is to create an education reform news
service a vertical news organization
dedicated to ed reform the way ESPN is
dedicated to sports or Bloomberg to
finance and you're going to so you're
going to be producing pieces and
releasing them and distributing through
this what are the types of things that
you're going to be putting up so we're
going to doing investigative news pieces
on television style investigative video
news pieces about waste fraud abuse
abuse and corruption in regular district
public schools about positive charter
school and private school turnaround
stories legislative updates where there
are there's tenure reform Roger bills or
charter capsule and this will be
national in scope indeed so anywhere in
the country the stories happen are there
are there regions where more interests
and stuff is happening than others maybe
sometimes the places that are heavily
unionized you get more than Madison
Wisconsin types for us earlier this year
where people are actually just freaking
out in protests everywhere and and i
went there and heard some of the people
by the way and we did a screening it's
sold out screening right the middle of
all that in Madison California's got a
lot going on as does
New Jersey and Indiana and a lot of
places where unions of the songs is
there is there a tipping point coming in
school reform where suddenly you know a
million flowers bloom and choice
actually wins out I'm not sure I would
model it as a tipping point it seems to
be more like a barge that's we're trying
to turn around and sits in the other
direction so while I think a lot of
parts and minds have been changed a lot
of the laws haven't been yet so if you
look at the percentage of kids are in
schools of choice right now in America
it's still under five percent run in
every state the progress in the movement
has been changing a lot of hearts and
minds which is really only about two
years old quite frankly I mean you had
my fill in the cartel waiting for
superman nbc's education nation series
reason has done a lot of girls stuff
that said in terms of how where the laws
all right now and the percentage of kids
who are going to schools of choice
meaning something besides the normal
public run district school ninety-five
percent of kids are still going to those
schools right and or more than that in
every state so while people are talking
about these issues more and kind of
getting the idea you know maybe teacher
tenure isn't such a great idea right
those laws haven't been reformed hardly
anywhere right yet and so the inner
embryonic effort still and that's why
we're doing talk a bit about choice
media TV the venture it's going to be
coming online in early September around
Labor Day something like that how does
that fit into a new media landscape I
mean that helped prove helped you create
and circulate and distribute your movie
at the cartel but what you know is is
this a good time to be doing alternative
media sure when we when he first start
with the idea I was kind of thinking we
would try a PBS show which are hosted
before and had nationally syndicated and
kind of use an old media model and and
the more I looked into it the more i
talk to people they're just kind of
telling me like that's the old way to
think that that would be much better
designing an iPad
and an iphone app and Android and nook
and kindle and try to get your content
out that way because that's the
direction this is not hitting especially
if you spin it forward you know two to
five years I think we're the kind of
linear model of the cable television
network or broadcast networks he's just
going to go away right now and so we
wanted to prepare ourselves for that
thang eventual so do you think that
school choice is you know it's part of a
larger wave of consumer choice and a
lifestyle choice and if so how long have
which what's your best guess on how long
it's going to take to really get to a
place where school choices the norm
rather than you know something that has
to be argued to that where our job is
done and we'll be able to a closed shop
like Jerry Lewis used to say on the
lucky muscular dystrophy telethon will
have cured it and the time run close it
down well she predictions alike that
would be hard i would say how long did
it take this get into this mess but at
least five years and probably ten and
probably more so it'll be a long time
because there's so many places where
people don't even know what a voucher is
they don't know what a charter school is
and so it's a lot of work to do well Bob
babin director of the cartel heading up
now choice media TV thank you very much
for talking to reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie